em 5 de março de 2001 foi o início da
minha carreira nessa profissão super
inovadora chamada médica foi o primeiro
dia de aula na faculdade de medicina
eu posso dizer pra vocês com convicção
que o fator humano é a razão pela qual a
maioria de nós
escolhi essa profissão tão exigente
a gente quer ajudar outros seres humanos
a gente quer cuidar de pessoas e é
dotado de se proteger esse propósito
nobre que a gente senta na sala de aula
e se depara com algo desse tipo
e aí no primeiro dia de aula que vem o
choque de realidade
os médicos eles não aprendem sobre
pessoas mas sim sobre doenças e elas são
ensinadas por absolutamente todas as
perspectivas anatômica bioquímica
histológica - uma a do paciente
a principal receita para formar médicos
foi estabelecida em 1910 por uma
publicação chamada de relatório flex ter
antes dele não existiam diretrizes para
a criação de faculdades de medicina
muito menos consenso a respeito do que
elas deviam ensinar cada uma define a
mais ou menos a própria fórmula bom e
nesse quase 100 bom na verdade nesses
mais de 100 anos muita coisa mudou no
mundo mas pouca coisa mudou na educação
médica assim como a linha de produção de
uma fábrica a esteira da formação médica
segue gerando do mesmo jeito
alternando patologias e tratamentos para
diferentes órgãos a cada momento
de manhã ortopedia e neurologia a tarde
psiquiatria e cardiologia
bom esse modelo na verdade ele fazia
sentido até mais ou menos 1900
50 que era quando a quantidade de
conhecimento médico do mundo
levava 50 anos para duplicar desde 2010
esse processo ele já acontece a cada
dois anos ou seja um estudante que
entrou na faculdade em 2010 até o fim do
curso em 2016 já viu a quantidade de
conhecimento médico dobrar duas vezes e
há previsões inclusive de que isso vai
começar a acontecer a cada dois meses e
meio a partir de 2020
o ano que vem né o pub médico que é a
principal plataforma que a gente médico
e estudante utiliza para se manter
atualizado já conta com mais de 29
milhões de artigos científicos só no ano
passado foram incluídos 1 milhão e meio
novos nem com todos os neurônios do
nosso cérebro a gente consegue dar conta
disso tudo né
e mesmo que a gente conseguisse esse
nosso modelo focado em tratar pacientes
dentro de consultórios e hospitais
baseado no resultado de exames físicos e
laboratoriais
ele corresponda só 10% de todos os
fatores que influenciam a saúde o bem
estar de uma pessoa
ele deixa de lado os 90% restantes a
composição genética e algo que a gente
chama de determinantes sociais da saúde
que nada mais são que o conjunto do das
condições sócio econômicas em que essa
pessoa vive dos comportamentos escolhas
que ela tem no dia a dia e do ambiente
físico em que ela reside é basicamente
tudo o que a torna humana né
então se não bastasse todo esse
conhecimento científico da medicina que
aumenta de forma exponencial
tem um outro conhecimento que é o
conhecimento sobre aquela pessoa aquele
ser humano um conhecimento que poderia
nos ensinar muita coisa mas que acaba
sendo deixando de lado
na verdade até desprezado e é engraçado
como
quando os nossos planos de tratamento
enquanto médicos não saem como esperado
e alguma complicação acontece seja um
quadro uma embolia uma infecção depois
de uma cirurgia
a gente ainda fica surpreso e se
pergunta porsche o que será que
aconteceu eu estudei tudo eu fiz tudo
certo
ou então se os pacientes evoluem mal
porque ele não seguiram as nossas
recomendações ou não tomar os remédios
corretamente a culpa é deles né porque
afinal eu sou uma boa médica o remédio
que eu prescrevi era certo e foi assim
que eu aprendi começa a ficar claro
inevitável o descompasso que estabelece
são milhões de multidões de pessoas que
querem e precisam ser tratados como
seres humanos únicos sendo atendidos por
médicos tratados treinados para tratar
doenças como se eles falassem dois
idiomas diferentes fica impossível a
comunicação ea parceria né
eu entendo é muita informação para
qualquer profissional processar mas a
realidade é que em 2019
a medicina ainda falha no propósito
principal dela que é de entregar para as
pessoas aquilo que elas precisam
a saúde é cada vez mais complexa ea
gente ainda insiste ensinar aos futuros
médicos a base a todos os tratamentos em
10% do todo esse modelo que embasado na
memorização de conhecimento técnico
informações desconexos
ele traz bernal ti ele o fusca a
proeminência da empatia na hora do
atendimento clínico ele limita a
criatividade ea nossa capacidade de
realmente ajudar os pacientes e resolver
problemas
esse modelo eles realidade ela não vai
mudar
não enquanto as faculdades de medicina
do século 21 e se insistirem em operar
no sistema operacional do século 20
ele precisa ser mais adequado a 1
até a atual que é o mundo da quarta
revolução industrial que faz com que
tecnologias que antes eram disponíveis
apenas para grandes corporações começam
a ficar cada vez mais acessíveis baratas
e se tornem grandes aliados capazes de
nos ajudar em tempo real 24 horas por
dia e sete dias por semana é um mundo em
que a gente tem computadores smartphones
capazes de processar dados de uma forma
que a gente nunca conseguiu nem
conseguiria sozinho só nos nossos bolsos
no celular a gente tem mais poder
computacional do que os computadores da
nasa que levar o homem até a lua na
década de 60 e desde 2014 aqui no mundo
a gente já tem mais sensores e
dispositivos móveis do que pessoas
captando dados o tempo inteiro desde o
número de passos que a gente dá o número
de copos de água que a gente toma um dia
até se o ar que a gente respira no nosso
trajeto até o trabalho está poluído ea
gente tem a inteligência artificial
capaz de analisar esses dados todos e
trazendo possibilidades do tipo a gente
analisar constantemente os batimentos
cardíacos de uma pessoa por meio de
sensores inteligentes dos relógios e
avisar o médico eo próprio paciente no
caso do surgimento de uma arritmia que
se não fosse identificada poderia levar
a um avc importante sequelas
a gente já consegue utilizar isso para
ajudar no diagnóstico de câncer de pele
por meio de aplicativos que usam a
câmera do nosso celular para avaliar a
lesões de pele suspeitas e até mesmo a
identificar casos de depressão e alta
probabilidade de suicídio por medo da
análise do padrão de uso das redes
sociais seja pela escolha de palavras ou
até o tom de voz
agora imagine o impacto disso em regiões
carentes ou regiões que têm poucos
médicos especialistas como é o caso dos
dermatologistas e dos psiquiatras
isso pode inclusive ajudar a priorizar
aquelas pessoas que precisam de
atendimento mais urgente
hoje pra vocês terem uma idéia a gente
já consegue cruzar todos os dados de
prontuários de um paciente com câncer
com a literatura científica mundial
disponível até aquele momento isso
trazer pro médico no momento da consulta
uma lista dos tratamentos que têm mais
chance mais probabilidade de dar certo
para aquele paciente está na frente dele
na hora da consulta pra quem não sabe a
oncologia é uma das especialidades em
que é mais difícil se manter atualizado
principalmente por conta do número de
estudos e recomendações que saem a todo
tempo
isso ajuda muito o médico a tomar a
decisão na hora que está na frente do
paciente ea gente consegue ter acesso a
isso tudo não só dentro do consultório
ou do hospital mas também por plataforma
de telemedicina e de ferramentas na
nuvem e é essa convergência de
tecnologias que aparece como um meio
para a gente começar a enfrentar os
desafios de saúde do século 21 porque
ele traz a promessa inédita de começar a
entender do ponto de vista médico a
singularidade de cada indivíduo ea
promessa de entregar um atendimento
melhor muito mais personalizado e
eficiente
é isso que aumenta a precisão dos
diagnósticos que aumenta a eficácia dos
tratamentos e até nossa capacidade de
tomar medidas para prevenir doenças
é isso que mais do que me tornar uma
profissional melhor ou me trazer
vantagem competitiva no mercado é isso
que vai tornar a vida do meu paciente
aquele ser humano melhor
só que nada disso pode se tornar
realidade eu ganhar escala
se os médicos temem ou nem estão
conscientes dessa transformação
um estudo feito na inglaterra em 2018
mostrou que quase 70% dos médicos não
acreditam que a inteligência artificial
vai influenciar o ato de fazer
diagnóstico e mais 60% não acreditam que
isso vai nos ajudar a traçar planos
tratamentos personalizados é como se a
mentalidade da maioria dos meus colegas
tivesse ficado com escolar piolla na
grécia antiga e isso é muito preocupante
e é algo que acontece porque o número de
faculdades de medicina que possuam em
sua grade de disciplinas que abordem os
impactos da transformação digital e das
novas tecnologias na carreira médica ele
ainda é mínimo
então ao invés da gente fazer os nossos
estudantes decorarem as artérias do
polígono de willis o cascata de
coagulação a medicina precisa de um
contra o alt del de reiniciar o sistema
visando ensinar os médicos aprendem no
mundo digital
priorizando a capacidade de encontrar
avaliar e sintetizar a informação e de
comunicar isso com clareza e empatia
para os pacientes
pra isso as grades curriculares precisam
urgentemente começar a incluir
fundamentos decência de dados de como os
algoritmos funcionam e de como tomar
decisões na hora de tratar um paciente
com o auxílio de ferramentas
tecnológicas
a tecnologia é implacável e é
invariavelmente transforma a maneira
como as pessoas interagem e trabalham ea
medicina não é exceção nesse processo
só que se a gente educar os médicos para
o mundo digital
a gente tem a chance de fazer com que
esse processo ocorra de forças de dentro
pra fora e não de fora para dentro sendo
impostas a nós porque daí a gente
consegue decidir como e onde essa
tecnologia toda deve ser utilizada para
trazer melhores resultados e aquilo que
é melhor deixar sendo feito da maneira
tradicional mesmo
daí ao invés da gente querer prever como
vai ser uma consulta médica daqui a 20
anos ou temer que a inteligência
artificial mas esse asteróide que vai
destruir a gente que nem fez com os
dinossauros
a gente pode permitir que os futuros
médicos usem essas ferramentas para
começar a construir o futuro que é
melhor pra eles
e para os pacientes deles hoje bom no
dia 3 de julho eu recebi a segunda menos
a seguinte mensagem nas redes sociais
pra mim é mais um indício da necessidade
dessa mudança
boa noite doutora mariana desculpe estar
a enviar mensagem eu sou estudante de
medicina e vi vários vídeos seus abateu
temáticas como a inteligência artificial
na medicina e eu só queria questionar
uma coisa
acham mesmo que a inteligência
artificial não vai substituir os médicos
eu sou apaixonado por medicina e meu
sonho era exercer e poder ajudar muita
gente com conhecimento que vai ter a
inteligência artificial sinceramente me
assusta um pouco obrigado e desculpe o
incômodo não há dúvidas de que os
algoritmos a inteligência artificial e
as novas tecnologias como um todo vão
transformar a medicina e obrigar a gente
a mergulhar para dentro de nós mesmos
buscando redefinir o papel do médico
nesses novos tempos
só que as características que definem um
bom médico elas nunca vão mudar
a medicina sempre vai precisar de pater
profissionais com coragem
vulnerabilidade e compaixão capazes de
olhar cada ser humano como um ser único
e atentos a todos os fatores que alteram
e podem influenciar a saúde dele ou dela
poucas coisas são tão humanas como isso
mas no mundo de hoje em que para cada
paciente se tornou um desafio de big
data
a gente não consegue fazer isso só com o
nosso cérebro a quantidade de informação
que a gente precisa levar em conta para
fornecer um cuidado de qualidade para um
paciente hoje já ultrapassa a capacidade
do nosso cérebro ea gente não consegue
mais fazer isso só com boa vontade
trabalho duro e muita cafeína a gente
precisa de ajuda
então da mesma forma que o telefone não
substituiu a voz humana e
aumentou o alcance dela e que o trator
não substituiu o músculo e sim aumentou
o poder dele
a inteligência artificial e as novas
tecnologias como um todo
começam a surgir como uma ferramenta
para ampliar o alcance dos nossos
cérebros é a nossa capacidade de
fornecer um cuidado melhor mais
personalizado mais eficiente e
conseqüentemente até mais humano por
mais irônico que possa aparecer no
século 21 é justamente a tecnologia que
pode nos ajudar fortalecer a relação
médico paciente ao permitir que a gente
trate de pessoas ao invés de doenças
primo nossa ela tinha significa não
causar dano
esse é o principal mandamento do
juramento de hipócrates que aquele texto
tradicional que a gente repete com muito
orgulho
num dos momentos mais emocionantes do
dia da formatura
eu acredito se as faculdades de medicina
reformular os seus currículos visando
ensinar os médicos aprendendo mundo
digital priorizando a gestão do
conhecimento ao invés da memorização a
se comunicar com os pacientes como seres
humanos integrais e não amontoados e
órgão sistemas ea usar a tecnologia para
ampliar as capacidades deles a gente vai
poder chegar na versão 2.0 do juramento
de hipócrates porque em 2019 não causar
dano é muito pouco a gente já tem os
meios para fazer com que esse mandamento
mude para finalmente fazer mais um bem
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]